all right how's it going guys
so there's one unfortunate
bit I discovered in our last playthrough
and that is that apparently we've hit
the point in the Harry Potter games
where
copyright starts becoming an issue
so
oh man they don't have a way to mute the
music in-game so I think what I'm gonna
have to do is just mute it
on the computer like on on the PC side
of things and then just play like
background music or something for you
guys and and me like that's what I'll
need to hear too
volte with the Super Chat
no fair retro gotta go to work soon
oh man volte sorry to hear that
thank you very much for the Super Chat
though and your continued support of the
channel here so yeah I mean the first
two parts of this game we streamed it
over on Twitch and I put up a poll
saying where do you guys want me to
stream Hogwarts Legacy and
this is on Twitter and YouTube just won
by a very large number
so I thought you know what we'll try uh
we'll hang out on YouTube for the day
hang out on YouTube for the day see how
this one goes and then we have Elwyn
gifting five memberships welcome to
house wrecking tour guys
so it's a little bit different the way
it works if you did happen to come over
from twitch
Works a little bit different than how
the subs work over there so Subs here
are free Channel memberships are the
paid membership the way you can support
a channel and Elwyn just gifted five of
them to you guys
so thank you so much elwin and congrats
to those of you who got one and also you
will get
the emotes you get to use the emotes
when you get a membership here and then
you also get uh discounted on merch a
couple of other things too if you just
go to our community page you can see
everything oh yeah I wanted to see what
what Casey was uh how are you
how are you come to Gryffindor Casey I'm
scrolling back up to see
so
Casey were you uh you have to remind me
did you just go on and like order one
yourself or were you like a contest
winner from our uh Christmas giveaway
I'll scroll back down now
yeah so did you order one on your own or
did you were you getting one from me
from the Christmas giveaway
good morning guys go ninja Susie
Sharon is here hanging out
Bristol boy what's up L Hooves who this
radio Morales you made it you made it my
friend yeah Dylan was talking earlier we
have uh inspector there's inspector yes
you made it inspector you made it dude
we were getting worried we were like
wait this inspector only follow us on
Twitter what if we will inspector still
be able to find us over here
so it is good to see you here inspector
so guys inspector's kind of like the
expert on Goblet of Fire we have
discovered and it's a very painful game
and a lot of times one of those times is
right now
so when I put out the tweet I put up the
post I was like I need you guys I I
really I need your help because
we're getting to kind of the grindy part
of the game here so we have played all
these levels that you've seen me
scrolling through
we've already made it through these
except Moody's challenges because as
Inspector informed us they don't do
anything there's not really any point to
them so we have made it through all of
these levels however they implemented
this weird system where to progress you
have to collect so many of these
tri-wizard shields and you can't collect
multiple ones in a single run of the
level
the only way to do it
is by going back you have to go back
replay them
and collect like one Shield at a time if
you ever see me collecting more than one
they're like mini Shields and I think
it's like 10 mini Shields or something
to make a big Shield very very annoying
so all these levels I've been scrolling
through apparently there are ways and
there are other ones hidden throughout
in fact I'm pretty sure there's one in
the prefix bathroom so we might start
with that one first here
we might start with that one first
oh it's a Hufflepuff shirt that your
nephew ordered
that's yeah if it's been a couple weeks
then that's probably been they should
have like an email confirmation I know
all the ones that we did for the
giveaway like got their way even faster
than they said they were going to
yeah so I don't know if uh on through
the spring website you should be able to
let use your tracking they should email
like whatever email you put in you
should have an Email tracking number
hopefully be able to to find it that way
finally catching a stream at a decent
time yeah well unfortunately I'm off
work today so
for those of you who are off work in
honor of Dr Martin Luther King Jr enjoy
your day off
as we remember Dr King and his legacy
but yeah so I'm off work today my wife
most of you who are regulars know she
works in the medical field so she's not
always off
I mean 365 right for for that line of
work
but yeah she just happened to be off
today too
kids are off school all just worked out
hey Jorge Velar welcome thank you for
subscribing to the channel
okay so I feel like we want to go
stamina and Jinx
boom right there
right there that's what I want for Harry
accio like I just feel like the accio is
not super useful
one of the biggest Zelda fans here never
beaten Wind Waker oh at the end yes the
little fetch quests at the end
yeah
I didn't mind it too much in Wind Waker
for whatever reason but I totally
understand I mean see at least with Wind
Waker it's like
it's just it's an open world so there
there is this sense of exploration
anyway
but here there's not it's not open world
it's not open world
it'd be so much better if it was open
world so this is the prefix bathroom and
let's see how many of these did we need
I think we said we needed 10 more of
these shields
10 more of these shields
so guys if you're uh if you're new here
yeah there's one right there actually
and we just unlock oh this one should be
super easy
oh there's two oh let's go dude
oh see just as soon as I thought hey
this is gonna be super easy
yeah I don't I'm not worried about axio
Ron
you need to do these not open up into
little yeah there we go
so we unlocked this new spell and our
last playthrough so now we should be
able to go back through a lot of the oh
there's another one up there
oh this is gonna be really nice if
there's three this close to the front
that would be really nice
wait that's the pre-mix bathroom right
yeah we were joking about that on last
time it's like
you know I don't want to insult game
developers they have a hard job and they
were probably under a big time crunch
for this game you know
but it's like whose idea was it to be to
you know they're sitting there
brainstorming and it's like okay guys
we need an idea for another level
it's Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire
you know one of the most
I mean if you look at a book that would
be a perfect video game it's gobble to
fire
you got all the challenges oh man I
think we're gonna have to go up there
and stop the uh
the flowing of that water somehow oh
that's annoying
that is super annoying okay and then
we've got one right here too
all right but the good news is we have
three that we can just we can really
see easy access to yeah it's like whose
idea would be to say all right guys
we're gonna we're gonna make a whole
level
out of the prefix bathroom that's the
one by the way H uh Julia I'm not sure
why your membership didn't pop up there
but thank you so much
oh and you know what I don't hear any
music right now
vermiculous
I don't hear any music so I
I mean hopefully oh it is kind of low
the music is lower
music is a bit lower
but hopefully I don't feel like it we
got when we did the prefix bathroom last
I don't feel like that one
detected anything
so for those of you who are just hopping
in we discovered unfortunately that
we've hit the point in the Harry Potter
video games where copyright becomes an
issue so I mean we can still post it
it's just a monetization we don't earn
anything off of it unless we go back in
and edit it out
so if you guys uh when you're watching
the replays or you're watching the other
ones if you notice any kind of weird
audio or looks like it like I cut
something out
that's probably what it was it's only
been a small section so far but it's
like it's like multiple small sections
all right so now I think we can go back
here
herbivicus
all right then we're gonna go here
I hope that we're close enough
are we close enough now to use accio
I don't think so and
huh we can't walk here
yeah right right the magickas extremus
Fernandez oh my goodness dude I haven't
seen your name pop up in a while it's
good to see you here man
yeah we don't normally get to stream
this early I'm I'm off work today so it
just it worked out nicely
I'm off work life's off work so
because you sometimes even when I'm off
work
I uh I'm watching my kids so you can't
really live stream
all right so wait that one might be the
easiest if we move that
okay hold on I think I see the path for
this one
I think I see the path golf work sick
today Alicia no
I mean I'm glad you're getting to watch
but I hate that you're you're sick how's
the new job going by the way
Alicia
also look guys the whole Rooster Chicken
idea yeah not a Hogwarts Legacy original
believe it or not
started all the way back here in the
Goblet of Fire
really inspector only got a few of the
easy shields in the prefix bathroom
level I'm not sure how to get some of
them
I know Elwyn for real I messed it up all
right guys Hey Ron Hermione one of you
come over
help please
or do I not actually need their help
with this I need their help with this
one right like guys why won't you walk
yep come on Hermione come come come come
come come come come come come come there
there
thank you Hermione
all right we need that full there we go
all right
combined cast
looking for a new job Gabe
I mean so our congratulations or good
luck or both in order
you know it's like whenever somebody's
looking for a new job it could be a lot
of things like he left the job he hated
okay or maybe maybe you didn't want to
leave and it didn't end well
or maybe it was just like a time to move
on thing you know
regardless if you're looking for a new
job I will I will say good luck to you
store welcome
dude that one that one's transformed
into a rabbit
oh my goodness elwin it just I mean it
works out it's like it's perfect for a
channel to be a moderator of a YouTube
channel it works perfectly
there we go
so many beans on this by the way all
right so now
Let's see we still need to get over to
hold on I know there's something
you can use them to explode oh wait
these things over here dude there could
very well be a a tri-wizard shield in
here
darn it oh yes let's go but I think this
is a mini one I don't think it's the big
one yeah so the big ones immediately end
the level the mini ones you have to
collect something like 10 of them
wubby good morning wubby how's it going
thank you guys for being here I know
it's a totally different time than we're
used to but some of you that may work
even better
because I know not especially our
friends uh
in totally different time zones can't
always make our late night Tuesday
streams
for a lot of people they end up being
early morning streams okay so wait we
gotta get over there to that one
all right you know what let's go ahead
and open this though while we've got
some help over here
everyone
Portugal Gallifrey wow I'm always amazed
at how worldwide our audience is
that is a big difference I've noticed
from
oh my goodness come on guys guys okay
Ron look okay see what I'm talking about
this game struggling look at this
look look at this dude
Ron buddy there there you go Ron yes Ron
This Way
okay how about Hermione you want to help
okay there there we go come come come
come there there we go guys look at that
teamwork
look at that teamwork
air animal welcome thank you for
subscribing
J ramble's Universe subscribing as well
thank you guys
and then uh let's see I saw Jenny in the
chat there we go all right that one
wasn't too bad
nine more to go guys nine more to go
new movie challenges
all right I really hope the prefix
bathroom oh wait and I do remember the
music was already
way too loud anyway
you know what why even take a chance why
even take a chance on this I'm
I'm not going to take a chance the
screen might get weird for a second
because I'm gonna have to uh yeah I'm
gonna have to take us no I don't want to
stop but I do want to go here
and let's see let's just completely mute
dolphin there we go
all right so yeah if you guys are just
jumping in and wondering why am I muting
the game audio it is unfortunately
because
this is the point in the Harry Potter
video games where copyright becomes an
issue but I do
have some music that we can play here
it's going to be kind of weird not
having the sound effects but honestly I
don't know if we'll want all the full
sound effects in this game anyway
all right that should be good for volume
right there
you're a wizard Harry
Ragnar subscribing to the channel as
well thank you thank you
never have an issue with loud music
lab athletic uh oh answering Casey's
question about the Sorting
over there
all right I'm gonna go right back into
the prefix bathroom if only because I
saw
two very very easy ones
by very easy I mean I can see them
no idea how hard they are to get to but
we could see them
that was a that was a good sign right
man I wish I could uh
so I'm trying out a new music too
because Spotify was letting me down as
well
all right this is Lo-Fi
all right we'll just let this one go for
a bit
let's go retro guy gaming uh
thank you for the four months my friend
good morning
to see you retro guy thank you for being
here
why did that not
oh that's just your message I was about
to say why did that not uh
why did that not notify on stream
uh so Jay Rambles here's how it goes
pretty much
the fourth one was just
I almost say universally bad but last
time we were streaming and I've even had
some comments on the other videos of
people saying oh no I actually I love
this one
I really enjoyed this oh okay you know
if you enjoyed it that's great
I feel like the consensus is that
most people did not enjoy this one
uh there are a lot of technical issues
with this one too like it's not just
but they completely changed up the style
of the game it's not open world anymore
it was split up into these levels
instead very very annoying and and very
unusual
considering the good thing that they had
going I mean they were building
something I think oh wait there's
another one down here
down here dude there's so okay look at
this there's three we can see right here
welcome to Gryffindor hey Fernandez
Duarte I always wonder if I pronounced
your name correctly
so looks like oh Dylan gifted five
Dylan thank you for the five gifteds
congrats to those of you who just got
one of the gifted memberships right
there from Dylan
[Music]
welcome you are now officially members
of house rack and tour oh dude can I
just literally walk
oh that was one of the mini ones though
darn it
now they're attacking okay so on the
positive side for minis though we we
need three more minis to get a full one
as well
So speaking of like the gameplay design
and the game decisions like why most
people didn't like this game
annoying fetch quests like required
fetch quests
it's like this is the only way to
progress the game at this point so so
bizarre
all right I wonder
I can't talk I wonder where I'm supposed
to put this one
Devin bird with the Super Chat yo thank
you Devin shout out to my mom she's
really nice oh that's very kind to be
shout out to Devin's mom
s are great right
you know most moms most moms I know some
people have you know
unfortunate childhoods hopefully
hopefully everyone has at least a a
motherly figure in their life
but and very kind of you to shout out
your mom as well
be kind to your mother's guys and gals
be kind to them all right so can we not
I thought for sure we'd be able to
destroy these pipes with the
there we go all right
okay so that destroys the pipes which
okay that makes this passable now so we
can go back and forth between here no
concern all right but what does that
really do to help us
okay so now we can also get here
but we cannot yet leap up there
we cannot yet leap up there
but I wonder if we can
is there another one of these blocks
here
or can we just use that one we might
just be able to use that one
oh and on the on the gifted memberships
guys make sure you think uh for anyone
who got one of the gifteds whether from
elwin or Dylan there
thank your gifter let them know you
appreciate it
feel free to spam the emotes
I always forget to remind you guys to
spam the niffler emote whenever we have
uh
super chats and stuff
we made this really awesome niffler well
I didn't make it but
I hired an artist to make it I love that
niffler emote it's so good
all right so can we not
can we not get that block right here
okay what if we
come on can we not lift it all the way
guys
all right I'm a little bit stumped
there we go there's that niffler emote I
love that emo dude whiskey neat welcome
thank you for the subs subscription
okay so we clearly need you're a wizard
Harry I I think that's the only way to
get up there let's make sure there's not
another yeah
I don't think there's another path where
we could like Drop from the right or
something I think you definitely have to
get in there from here and clearly I
mean they want you to be able to access
both sides that's why they have this
little uh
this little
cauldron right here that you can explode
oh we're in the prefix bathroom dude
we're in the prefix bathroom don't you
remember this from the book
what how could you how could you guys
forget the enormous Cavern
I think we have to stand on this it's
like a switch
dude that almost looks like the Deathly
Hallows right there
very close to it
how could you guys forget this
incredibly
important part of Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire
see this is why I think
all right this is kind of crazy but
maybe we have to bring it all the way
around
maybe if we bring it all the way around
we can lift it like one at a time
it's not moving at all now what is
happening
it's like Harry's on on ice skates or
something look at that he's just slight
okay here we go
yeah let's take it all the way around
here
and then I want to see if we can oh yes
there we go okay
okay this is good this is good
now that we've put it up there
see that's where that's where it started
jabberwock it started this cube right
here started on top of that
my goodness Harry
come on get yes let's go all right all
right all right
okay you just want to go all right yep
just take it all the way fine by me
fine by me okay this is good this is
good now we're gonna go up here
but yeah one of the Annoying gameplay
decisions is how they have you going
back to kind of find all of these
try was your crests try wizard Shields
whatever you want to call it don't you
guys remember that from the book too
when in order to progress Harry had to
like
go around and find these tri-wizard
shields
they said you cannot proceed
oh no I'm gonna need
I'm gonna need help from from the others
here all right Hermione come on can you
get up here Ron just like totally
bailing look at him down there he's down
there in the bottom right he's like I've
had enough of this
Hermione you can make that come on
hairy dude no just no that's not
Hermione
what
they're just they're not very smart in
this even Hermione
oh wait she's able to get it from there
come on
now we've got it it's like stuck but
look how Harry you see how he's like
flying backward
yeah that's not intentional
oh wait we moved it a little bit come on
we just gotta get it past those pipes
all right Ron is actually over here and
trying
there we go that's it all right all
right that should be good enough now
they're actually gonna wake up
and hopefully hop over here with me
all right let's just toss you out of the
way for a second
all right now we just need to wait are
they casting they look like they were
casting it on each other for a second no
Harry do not fall oh my goodness if he
fell
hey
I mean yeah I guess that works I guess
that works Majestic how's it going
welcome
yeah I just I happen to be off work
today for uh it's a holiday for those of
us here in the US how are you Martin
Luther King Jr Day many of us are off
work
off work today oh my goodness you guys
like this is how this is how ridiculous
the AI and the mechanics mechanics can
be in this game come on move it quick
before it responds
I think it's getting stuck on The
Cauldron over there
no
no fall
so all we're trying to do guys is you're
trying to get
Sarah thank you for becoming a channel
member welcome to house wrecking tour
just lift why is it not giving us any
lift
multiple oh come on come on lift lift
move
okay wait maybe if I like if I can get
Harry right back in here
is if I could push back on it
and it just fall and it crushed him you
know what's gonna happen is we're gonna
fling it off the side over there and
it's going to go all the way back down
and I'm just gonna I'm just gonna cry
my first ever time crying on stream
is it moving like inch by inch oh it's
because he keeps falling
come on move it move it move it move it
no no The Cauldron again dude the
cauldron's in the way
oh
yes okay set it down nice and gently
there we go
there we go all right come on Boom okay
if you're wondering why are we doing the
same level over and over again it's
required it's required so that brings us
to
let's see how many crests are we at at
this point I think we need eight more
you guys the chat make it so much easier
to to go it makes it go faster
makes it go faster
that's why the game was a disappoint for
most right I mean just in a nutshell
just show them that clip right there
okay so I'm gonna stick with the prefix
bathroom though yeah we need eight eight
more ridiculous dude ridiculous
herbology is just terrible like that
level is just absolutely terrible so I
would like to avoid that one if at all
possible
um we've gotten all the dragon tasks
that one is is totally good and I think
we've gotten all the ones
possible from the lake as well
[Music]
see if I if I hit Y does it show me a
wizard Harry
[Music]
oh come on it doesn't show me how many
I wish it would show me
what is this words okay
I don't we don't need words in our music
I just want I just want the background
and uh Jay thank you for subscribing to
the channel Jay welcome
I'm pretty sure we got all the
tri-wizard
tasks
I'm pretty sure we did crying on stream
definitely gonna get some snifflers in
the chat
all right I mean we'll just go back to
the prefix bathroom
also if we find any more of the small
Shields too we're getting close on that
one as well
I think we need three more of those
so I know for sure all of the
task number one we got gold we got all
the ones
actually didn't with the underwater one
because we thought it was based on beans
for the dragon task it's not based on
time it's based on how many beans you
collect
I was just gonna see if there were any
is easy obvious ones over here oh I see
one over here
give us a hand Ron
[Music]
there we go
I mean I will say they actually
I feel like they had some good ideas for
this game
but like the Cooperative stuff it was
actually local co-ops it's like there
were some good ideas I like this idea of
working together they tried what they
try to do is take that idea from
Prisoner of Azkaban and sort of expand
on it
but it just didn't work out I mean they
maybe it was Rush development I don't
know
great here come these guys again all
right let's
there we go there we go
see it takes it takes forever to put the
fire out I thought it was out it's still
not out
it's still not out
don't see where to don't see where to
become a member
um so it's a little join button
if you're if you're on mobile you have
to go to like the main Channel page I
believe like if you click on my name
but yeah it is a little harder to find
on mobile if you're on desktop it's just
like right where the Subscribe button
would normally be but once you subscribe
then you can also become a member if you
want
probably the Harry Potter game you have
the most time in
uh because it was hard yeah I could see
that all right hold on hold on though
so we need to get back over to
I think I see the path
I feel like we just need to Carpe
retract them all of these
and then we we walk across pretty sure
we can jump up right there
foreign
come on like see like sometimes the
mechanics it just takes them
a little bit longer than it should to
even work
the world is full yeah
oh there's some there's some saying
that's like um
oh it's something about that something
about bad being the road paved with good
intentions yeah something like that
right so I think we can just can we just
go and drop down over here
can I fall
oh no tell me
okay accio's not strong enough
are you serious we cannot just drop down
right there oh no we can just do
herbivicus though
okay good yeah this was a good choice
this one was a good choice Elwyn this
one was actually
this one was actually easy
oh yeah you could tell the love and care
that's been shown to Hogwarts Legacy
even even with it not being out yet you
know
boom
all right all right we're making good
progress I was worried about this
all right about 40 minutes in we've
gotten that's three so far and we were a
little you know we so I'd say about 30
minutes of pure gameplay so far that
we've been playing maybe even less than
that actually
because I don't think we started the
gameplay right at 10.
first and third HP game for PS2 will be
playing those when finished with ghosts
of sushima well
those are actually decent those are
decent games
yeah
a bit of a drop off from Ghost of
tsushima though a bit of a drop off
there
all right so we need seven more
and we know about two for sure in the
prefix bathroom
see this is what I was hoping man I did
not want to have to go into that
herbology room for a lot of them
I'll show you guys the herbology one
here in a second
just so you all can see it if you've
missed our other previous streams
um but they're on the channel here the
Let's Plays are on the channel if you
guys want to check any of those out
part one and part two
so we stream those over on Twitch
and this one I was like you know what
let's try a YouTube stream we put up a
poll on YouTube you guys seem to prefer
YouTube for the live stream so who am I
man to go against the uh go against the
audience
all right that one
that one should be an easy one
without these dudes shooting at me
all right so I think all we need to do
I'm trying to chart out the path here
I think we need to go and
I think we just need to get across
let's do this one
we need to get over to those stairs on
the right side not the big ones up at
the top right
yeah if I'm a second son it's a good
game please don't show her apology
share it says it brings back trauma yeah
these these annoying dudes right here
mosps I think is what they're called
m-o-s-p
this is not the music of the game either
guys we had to uh mute the music
[Music]
due to copyright man so frustrating so
frustrating like it'll stay on YouTube
but
then you can't earn anything off of
those videos
all right so yeah I think we're oh no
we're not gonna this is not gonna work
either because we gotta move
we have to move that one
well let me just make sure
because it I mean it looks like in
reality in a normal game
there should be room to like slip by
right here like to just slip slip by
yeah I knew I knew they weren't gonna
let you they're like no you cannot walk
into the water
you cannot walk into this little bit of
water so we're gonna have to get up
above this one first
wait for Hogwarts Legacy is killing you
um it's I mean dude it's right around
the corner now
it is right around the corner everybody
was saying like this month's gonna drag
by I don't think so
I don't think so I'm just like I still
feel like I have so many videos I want
to make before
and with last week I mean how much news
we got you guys
it's this week gonna hold you know
and in the lead up to launch people are
already seeing uh commercials and stuff
and Cinemas
TV all the uh I've loved seeing the
buses
that is so cool I don't think we found
ravenclaws yet though shout out to the
ravenclaws in the chat
Jay Rossi welcome Jay Rossi wizard Harry
you're a wizard Thiago thank you for
subscribing to the channel
yeah I really do I feel like the month
is flying by and I I get it it's
different when you're
Ollie there's that one too
okay yeah but that one you have to get
yeah this is the one we're going after
this is the one we'll be going after
right here okay so we're gonna go across
the lily pads now we've moved the water
all right let's go up here
oh no don't don't try and fight me don't
try and fight me uh I guess we gotta
fight these guys no choice they just
absolutely wrecked our buddy Ron right
there
they just poor Ron
all right there we go look at all those
beans man look at all those dirty pots
every flavor beans so here's a question
about Hogwarts Legacy
birdie bought beans hadn't been
vented yet if I'm right I think I'm
right on that welcome to Griffith so
instead it's like as we fight all of
these people are we going to be getting
just regular money like galleons sickles
knuts
I'm kidding I know it's canutz but
I still prefer knuts
it's not nuts the K is not silent
believe it or not believe it or not
regulars know that regulars of the
stream already know cygnus jabberwock
with the
Channel membership welcome to house Rec
and tour my friend thank you for
choosing to become a member there
dude you know what should I go ahead and
do this one too while we're over here we
probably should but
why is it not okay there it goes finally
see I wish you could just like drop off
the side Take A Little Fall damage right
come on where's a Resto momentum when
you need it
where's the rest so momentum when you I
just want to drop off right there
all right well that's good so now we
know how to get that one too and then
we're gonna have to oh that one's gonna
be super annoying because you also have
to move that Fountain over there
[Music]
all right so wait did we move this one
did we get it
we did we got
it all right I don't know why I didn't
think we'd gotten that one yet
the word canutz makes you giggle
now we oh we gotta bring the lily pads
back using habibacus
yeah you could see it Sarah in some of
the cutscene or in the uh some of the
trailers you can see
but yeah I guess we would instead of
getting
because we know like looting is in the
game so I guess after we
disarm Wizards or
all you evil wizards out there after you
AK them I guess you'll be able to walk
over and like
loot the bodies
yeah Jack I hope so too that's uh
they're definitely listening
I gotta say the WB game support Twitter
account
they have been answering a lot of
questions
a lot of questions
uh wizard PhD
AKA Prof Lynette did a really nice
Twitter post kind of pulling together a
thread of all that they have been
revealing
because they've been answering a ton of
questions that people have been sending
in
like save slots so if you guys didn't
see safe slots have been officially
confirmed multiple save slots which I
didn't even know that was a thing of
games not including it
[Music]
that is so bizarre to me that games
would not include multiple save slots
and I mean I guess you could always get
around it by having multiple users on
your system like that like for my PS5 I
have a username and my son has a
username so the save the saves are tied
to each username so I guess that's what
I don't know some companies are
expecting that people just use that
but yeah they've been answering a lot of
a lot of questions
all right so we're basically gonna have
to do every single thing we just did
or do we or do we
all right so
herbivicus on all that over there yeah
I'm just totally ignoring these dudes
I was not even paying attention as
they're blasting me with their little
darts
yeah having that extra stamina as Harry
comes in really handy yeah I think it
was four Raven bus did we finally spot
the Raven Bus Let's Go
yeah I was fooled there was somebody who
uh just like photoshopped the Slytherin
one a few days ago
and I posted I I shared it and I was
like oh somebody pointed out I looked
closer very clearly at Photoshop
it's like you know it's bad man when
people are resorting to
trying to photoshop
the Ravenclaw bus
oh no Sarah like I at this point I'm not
ruling anything out I'm really not
just because of how they've been
surprising us so much and they keep
saying tip of the iceberg right that
there's there's a lot more to be
discovered
like look at look at them man they're
totally useless like I'm trying to put
out the fire you guys could be focusing
on the fire salamander
come on
all right now just yeah get that guy out
of here all right let's get this one now
tag me nice Ryan thank you foreign
yeah I mean not even multiple
playthroughs but just like families that
you know don't have a bunch of different
accounts set up and brothers sisters
husbands wives you know
mothers and daughters Fathers and Sons I
mean that that want to
share in this game together
Jeremiah oh my goodness Jeremiah well
thank you for the Super Chat yes we were
just answering and talking about that
one yeah so it seems like four save
slots
I think is what I read
WB game support account on Twitter has
responded to some folks with the answer
to that but yeah I'm pretty sure it said
four
hey no problem twice I'm I'm always down
for some day streams whenever I'm not
working at my normal job
and can make it work with with the
family
and yeah it just worked out today
come on
come on
pull it down
oh dude that's so cool Ryan I love that
that's a great idea
are they have they confirmed if they are
just in the UK are they also in the U.S
I would love that if they were
all right so we're gonna have to uh
okay I think we have to go to the other
side to move that other fountain
wait wait is this a hidden Passage
see how the camera like goes back a
little bit like there's something in
there
uh yeah we'll be live tomorrow as well
tomorrow night so for like our normal
Tuesday night stream yeah we'll be live
at uh 8pm eastern time Tuesday evening
for our regular retro record Tour live
stream
yeah this is just uh I've been trying to
do more gameplay streams and this just
worked out this day just worked out
oh you don't think four is going to be
enough I think four is enough
unless you just have a really big family
and only one username
but yeah I was asking some people I was
talking to Nico on Twitter was like wait
is this
I didn't understand why people kept
wanting to know about that I'm like of
course they're gonna have multiple safe
slots because I I just thought that was
a gibbon I mean 2023 I thought that was
a given that video games have multiple
save slots but apparently not
apparently some of the bigger uh some
bigger recent games have not had
multiple safe slots I think Callisto
protocol didn't one of the Assassin's
Creed games didn't
which is just bizarre to me
I mean there have been multiple save
slots since memory cards first started
becoming a thing
oh we're actually kind of running low a
little bit on health right here
thank you I am ridiculous thank you very
much appreciate it
thank you for your support hanging out
here on this uh Monday evening or Monday
Monday evening
I'm so used to saying evening on this
Monday afternoon Monday morning whatever
it may be for you guys we got
an audience a global audience people
around the world
all right you know what I'm just gonna
go ahead and move this one too
[Music]
just to make sure we have a full path
down there okay wait so that one oh did
we forget about that one
we did I knew there was another one
all right so that's okay though because
it looks like we have to go back over
there anyway
all right and then we're gonna go down
those steps
all right so that one right there chat
do not let me forget
do not let me forget
almost forgot memory cards existed right
yeah I think there's a bunch of auto
save slots go ninja I think there's a
bunch
yeah don't don't quote me on it guys
it's uh the WB game support account or
if you just check proflanet with your
phds Twitter she did a big thread
okay wait for this one yeah yeah yeah we
have to go over here
[Music]
the white Hogwarts Legacy theme bust no
what's on that one Devin is that one of
the houses or
multiple characters I mean yeah I guess
you could do multiple characters if you
wanted
or if you had like multiple people in
your family wanting to play the game on
different different saves
but see like I was saying if you're on
PS5 I'm sure it works this way on Xbox
as well you set up you have multiple
users on the system and so those
multiple users
why is it oh my goodness Harry what are
you doing dude
all right
no don't I knew it oh dude we're
actually running really low on the
chocolate frogs so chocolate frogs are
what handle the revives in this game
we're down to four of them now or did
that just say three all right fine I
actually I'm gonna have to fight these
guys really
they haven't presented this much of a
problem at all this whole run through
this whole run
[Music]
I got you now dude I got you 46 I'm
already down to 46 Health please just
eliminate this guy
or or better yet yes just please form
this Harry
Majestic tea
thank you for the membership
thank you so much welcome to house rack
and tour enjoy your emotes oh yeah I'm
gonna eat this really quick
all right come on we gotta stun these
guys
how is it hitting me I'm I'm literally
like trying to run and Dodge
it's like as I've collected more they've
gotten more aggressive
I'm about dead I'm about dead again
[Music]
dude if they if see now I'm down to two
chocolate frogs if these things ruin
this for me to where we have to redo
this all again
stop it oh my goodness
okay stunts done this one stun this one
the other one's stunned
my teammates are just not doing anything
right now you can't decide which house
to do
just go with uh go with the Wizarding
World quiz
wife and I had to get a PS5 once this
was announced even after the delays and
everything glad it drops the day after
your birthday nice that's a good
birthday
I'm a February birthday as well mine's a
little bit later in February though
all right so now we've moved that one
I think we can finally get this one
let's just hope we don't encounter
oh dude there's more of those Moss
there's more of those Moss
I know Voldemort might have actually won
the war Dylan if he had had these guys
if Voldemort had had these dudes on his
side like
come on come on yes Hermione now see now
that's like Hermione distracting him
right there I love it
that was very helpful Hermione
very helpful took that hit for the team
oh no I've gotta form this one too
gotta form this one too
bday is the day before Greg nice
[Music]
I don't know if I should tell you guys
my birthday chat
[Music]
somebody might try to steal my identity
with that
oh dude
it's uh we'll just say it's it's late
February late February
all right there we go boom
hopefully companion combat and AI is
good useful well I'll tell you this
immortal
I can lock in that it's gonna be better
than this
I can lock it in
I can I can guarantee you it will be
better than what we are experiencing
right now
oh I gotta check this tweet I gotta
check out the Ravenclaw bus here
yo there's Ryan with the tag thank you
Ryan
oh they got some good pictures of this
one too
oh that blue looks so nice
that blue looks so nice on that
Ravenclaw bus
oh man
yeah it looks like somebody found the
bus garage
all right congrats ravenclaws
your day has come
all right
yeah that was such I love that
advertising that's such a fun idea man
such a fun idea to do those big
like like wraps it's I've I've been I've
never actually designed one of those
wraps but I've done some graphic design
work and like seen the files for those
things man
is such a fun type of design to work on
all right let's see did we find all of
the
Justice for the ravenclaws
[Music]
all right
not feeling this one
yeah I'm trying a new music service too
so
all right let's see if it marks out
hopefully it marks out once you've
completed everything
all right how many do we need oh five
all right we've cut into it
we've cut into it by halfway guys
halfway
the speed run for this game is crazy one
hour of just ignoring everything I'd
love to do that shadow guided
how do they how do they collect
like what's the I guess the quickest way
to collect all the tri-wizard shields
because as far as I know there's no way
to progress this right
like there's no way to progress there's
only two levels left I mean we're almost
there guys you're a wizard but we just
have to it won't even open up that next
level until you collect
I got five more Shields we need to do
all right I'm just gonna go into the
prefix bathroom
I'm just gonna go in
uh welcome Paul and Sarah thank you for
subscribing to the channel
why doesn't Xbox have this game I'm
pretty sure Xbox I'm pretty sure this
was on Xbox right
this is the GameCube version I know for
sure it was on PS2
oh no I didn't mean to do that I liked
my other Loadout better
I want a good balance of stamina and
the jinx
actually I was gonna say at this point
we might just need to put everything
into stamina
focusing on Surviving all right there we
go that'll be good
uh you know what let's put give Hermione
a little bit more
that works
and then Ron can we get Ron's stamina up
a bit
but also give him a balance give him
some good Jinx oh there we go I'll take
that
it was on original Xbox I thought so
yeah yeah I thought it was foreign
ERS videos dude
yeah Flanders done some really nice deep
dive videos
on the old on the old Potter games all
right so apparently I mean surely they
wouldn't let you go into the level if
you'd gotten everything
right
that may be risky me saying that
that could be risky
all right I don't see any over here I
feel like this whole section is done
I could be wrong but I I feel like that
section is done I'm gonna go a different
way
a way that we haven't went recently
okay we went that way I'm gonna go over
here
oh in the store
I see yeah yeah you probably gotta find
an old hard copy
for Xbox
these game I mean especially this game
was not very well received so you can
find these pretty cheap most of the time
all right so we can make that jump right
there
all right let's go ahead and use this to
destroy that there might very well be a
mini shield in there
yes Perfect all right that's eight mini
Shields so one we need two more mini
Shields
gotta head out Shadow guided a all good
shadow guy I appreciate you stopping by
and saying hello hope you have a great
day my friend
Lorena there's no way of knowing how
much is left right I feel like I've got
to be missing something I feel like
there has to be somewhere that tells you
you still need this mini in this level
all right but you know what I'm not
gonna complain about
so I'm just like I'm able to kind of
explore freely right now
there we go
oh you got digital I see I see there are
five buses yeah somebody was saying
something about a white there's like a
white version or something
all right so this one we have to drop
off the side I remember this
all right so that destroys that
okay so I wonder if we
I don't think there's a way to push this
down
there's not you have to Carpe retract
them it from the other side
[Music]
only Potter game you can play on Xbox is
Lego Oh you mean like digitally
because yeah they should all be on
the hard copies should should be on
no I didn't mean to fall
all right so I don't see anything there
let's go ahead and run through here
oh no I don't think we can get by here
oh there was one more guys
there was one more that we didn't move
oh and now the enemies come out I knew I
spoke too soon
I knew I spoke too soon
there's a white one that has the game
key are on it oh that's so cool
I haven't seen that one yet do we have
do we have visual
oh you just tagged it oh nice Dylan
let's see Where'd I put my phone
[Music]
let's see
[Music]
where is it
[Music]
why don't I see it Dylan
on Twitter or maybe on you might have
done on Discord huh
[Music]
oh man did you do it on Discord Dylan
[Music]
I'm not seeing it on Twitter
oh the Tweet was deleted no
[Music]
they weren't supposed to show it yet
or maybe there was just a typo sometimes
companies do that you know make like a
typo and then just repost it
oh now the enemies come out can I
disrupt
uh I'm eastern time cygnis Eastern Time
thank you
uh yeah Dylan should be able to post
links Dylan's a mod here so if Dylan's
able to find them I'm totally fine with
Dylan posting that here in the chat
if any of you uh if anybody else tries
to post links it's probably not going to
let you I think I have it turned off
oh my goodness you were about to get
destroyed I'm just I'm rushing too much
man
I'm rushing too much
oh no we can't die we cannot die jump up
here jump up here jump up here Harry
all right all right let's regroup right
here let's regroup
I'm pretty sure we can drop this over
here
but I also want to go ahead and grab
this let's pull this down
oh they repost it nice that could be
what it was
maybe just a typo on the original
somewhere
yeah feel free to post it here too Dylan
if I think YouTube should let you where
you're a mod I think it will let you
post the link
yeah guys so we have uh siding of all
four of the Hogwarts Legacy house buses
and apparently there's a fifth bus as
well that features the key art for the
game
very very cool
all right so let's see did we already
move this one no we didn't
but I can't move this one alone I'm
gonna need help
and they're still hanging out down here
fighting
I know running it's like the Dark Souls
method you know
why haven't they destroyed them yet like
why is it taking them so long to destroy
this guy
specifically
I've been uh so I should be going in
order so we replayed we have Let's Plays
up on the channel for uh Philosopher's
Stone on PC we have Let's Plays up for
the Chamber of Secrets console version
then we have Prisoner of Azkaban console
version and then this was just the next
one you know
just the next one
and then after this we will move to uh
Order of the Phoenix
which is actually decent like that one's
a decent game
why is it come on guys
use your strength
all right so I really need I really need
to find some
cauldron cakes or something oh no these
guys are back out again
no I don't want the chicken I want I
want some health I want some healing
items
healing items please
all right well at least we didn't die to
them okay so let's kind of evaluate
where we're at now I don't like I said
they're not even showing us if there's
anything left in this level guys it's so
ridiculously annoying
all right I'm gonna go this way
oh yeah that's so
all right I'm just gonna go ahead and
pull this down
it was a weird
yeah yeah so you check them out twice
we've got them all uploaded here on the
channel
Let's Plays you know they don't
for whatever reason they don't get like
served on people's home pages as I mean
they're long videos right so guys
Hermione Ron like follow me please
please
I think with their longer videos they
just for whatever reason don't get
served up as well on home pages I guess
it's kind of like people probably don't
watch them
for very long
do you I mean I don't know I guess if
you're really into it you'd watch the
whole thing but sometimes people just
wanna they just want to see like oh man
this game look this game looked great or
I remember that part or this was
terrible
and then hop out
remaster on the ps6
hey thank you Elwyn there we go There's
the link
all right so I just did that I just
opened that up just to make sure but I
think we actually need to go this way
and I'm gonna have to watch out for the
spraying water I'm actually gonna have
to be patient here
because I only have 11 health
all right so does this one have okay now
that one doesn't
oh we need to destroy this right here
there might be a uh
no Harry oh
[Music]
look at them there's so many that just
just popped out
both links are faulty no
did they delete the tweets again
at first they posted it and then they
removed the tweet
oh my gosh these guys are so annoying
yeah I don't even think there's anything
left for us to find dude this is bad
because that's where you like you exit
the level right there what
why would they do this
okay so the only thing I can think of is
that there are minis somewhere in here
maybe right here
mini Shield mini Shield
uh
uh okay oh wait another one just pops
out randomly I think they endlessly
respawn right here
oh my goodness there's so many
there's so many right now
why are there so many
okay yeah guys I think we are officially
done with the prefix bathroom after this
I need to get that down right here
Hermione please help me quickly yes
hurry hurry hurry we've got to get this
down
come on come on come on there we go nice
all right
I think if if my guess is right I think
the only thing left for us to do in here
oh no I've already destroyed I've
destroyed both of these I know I did a
hundred percent
yep that one's been destroyed
the only thing I think could possibly
still be here is maybe one of the mini
Shields somewhere
but I'm not seeing any
all right well let's go back this way
no Harry dude that water does so much
damage too
let's be real hufflepuffs is the best
looking
I mean just my gut reaction
as a Gryffindor
the Ravenclaw blue looks so good I think
and I'm not just saying that
because the ravenclaws have been
patiently waiting
no there's not one here either are you
serious
oh this is bad guys this is really bad I
think we may have found all the ones in
the prefect level
thank you
I think we may have found all of them
yeah there's just something about that
Ravenclaw blue with the light the way
the light was hitting it in the picture
I saw
and I haven't seen inspector commenting
too much and Specter must be busy today
inspector was our our guide through the
first part two parts of this series
but inspector did say also that they did
not find many from this level so yeah I
mean I think that's it guys I think
we're gonna have to just exit
oh wait there's more
hold on what if they actually hid
something in here
[Music]
it's possible Right
wait Harry's stuck for some reason he
can't move
nothing nothing
rpeg Badger says Ravenclaw bus is best
saying that as a Hufflepuff
to be fair we also have the best
pictures of the Ravenclaw bus too like
those look like somebody really made
sure to get some nice shots Break The
Floor wait wait wait where where in here
where I'm at right now
oh my gosh we just destroyed Hermione
all right let's try it
I love you guys yes
yes
oh my gosh who had it first inspector at
it first let's go inspector and then RPG
Badger too
thank you guys that was clutch right
there I was about to exit the level
all right now let's see if it marks that
level as like complete let's see if it
Grays it out
because that would at least help me know
that if the level is showing as if it
appears then that means there's
something else you can do there
but if it doesn't then we're kind of at
a loss all right so we need four more
four more before we can progress
still selectable
all right so we need four more
we could we could dare to go into
herbology
prefix bathroom that one wasn't too bad
we already got all the ones for the
dragon so we've got Forbidden Forest and
Hogwarts exterior
I'm gonna try Forbidden Forest
because it's not
an incredibly painful level like the
other one
like the herbology
prefix bathroom's not too bad either
it's just at this point I'm tired of
seeing it and I I feel like we've gotten
I feel like we've exhausted that one
pretty well
by the way check out my uh
check out my Tervis here for drinking
out of today
one of my favorites this was a gift from
Mrs raconteur I can't remember if it was
Christmas or birthday many years ago
many years ago
inspector says herbology has the most
number of shields with easy access the
Flies are still the annoyance ah okay
okay
I'm just checking the tweets really
quick I want to see this uh
there we go thank you Dylan and
[Music]
oh I see yes yes yes
oh dude I can't wait till we see the
full
that is so awesome
so does it say they're just in
hitting the Streets of London
that's cool
so for those of you in the UK man what a
fun little scavenger hunt you guys can
do
so it says tweet a picture of any of our
five bus designs okay any of the five
bust designs and mention us for the
chance to win a Hogwarts so I can see
collector's edition on PlayStation 5 you
can interrupt to five times with a
picture of each bus oh that's very cool
terms and conditions apply
but if we're gonna have anything for the
U.S
[Music]
that is very cool though
I love it
yeah the marketing has certainly been
ramping up for sure
okay so we're gonna look I'm just gonna
look through the Forbidden Forest here
and then we will inspector says that
the uh herbology level has the easiest
so we'll go back to it knowledge what's
up narlet welcome good to see you again
yeah they haven't said anything about
for the US morvolo
I've not seen anything anyway
welcome Eagle Eye
good morning
or good afternoon let's see yeah it's
it's almost almost afternoon for me too
a rare day stream for us guys good to
see everybody here hanging out hope you
all are having a
wonderful Monday so far if you guys are
off work for those of you in the U.S who
are off for
Dr Martin Luther King Jr day enjoy your
day off
that is uh that's why I'm off that's why
I'm here streaming streaming with you
now
it is also very possible that we already
got everything here
what does this one do I think this just
gives you some beans
wow a single Bean okay not worth
not even close to being worth it
you're a wizard Harry
the sun only just started to rise Elwyn
oh my goodness Elwyn with those early
morning uh mod hours there
Cameron Cameron thank you for
subscribing to the channel
all right let's see
the little cursor that you aim with is
just so
I mean it's like they could have picked
just about any other color
but it's like this dark Kind of navy-ish
Blue
there we go
oh of course it didn't put it out all
the way
of course it didn't
I mean you could have just went safe you
could just went safe with like a solid
white coloration
it would have been much more visible
that one's so hard to see
all right so I thought I saw something
like back in here
yeah right up here
oh it's just a little uh
pumpkin Pasty
now we also have these little guys yo
100 likes nice thank you guys
thank you for all the likes
that does help more people find the
video in this case find the live stream
all right so let's see if we can uh
we'll have to come up with something
different for uh something fun we can do
when we hit like Milestones on the
gameplay streams
I don't want to I don't want to break
like the immersion of the
so normally guys we stream on Tuesday
evenings and we do um
it's more like a podcast talk show kind
of thing
and whenever we hit 100 likes we do a
random quote from the Harry Potter
series
but here I feel like we need something
different I don't want to break the uh I
don't want to break our gameplay you
know
okay so we got a cube over here
we just need I just need to find one in
this level and that's all I care about
even if we could find a couple minis in
here
the tri-wizard crests
8 23 a.m for you Jenny
man you guys pulling the early early
hours
oh you're in Canada as well Jenny no way
we've got several uh several Canadians
here in the community
yeah yeah Devon we'll still be live uh
tomorrow night as well yep
still going live tomorrow night talking
about whatever uh Hogwarts Legacy
decides to reveal maybe they'll maybe
they'll reveal something today
if not maybe tomorrow last week was just
crazy dude
which we haven't even talked about all
that stuff on stream so we're gonna have
plenty to talk about
I'm working on a so my next big video is
gonna be a lore based video
on all of the
like the story that we know so far all
the characters because we got a lot of
new stuff man a lot of new stuff
with all the character reveals last week
so the ministry I mean I don't want to
spoil it or get into it too much here so
we'll save it for the
the Tuesday night crowd but
man the ministry there is something
the ministry it's its hands are all over
Hogwarts Legacy
so many of the professors what Harry
so many of the professors have
connections to the ministry formerly
work there
we just got confirmation that the so the
guy riding in the carriage with with you
in the beginning of the game well we
assume it's the beginning of the game
but he's riding with you and fig at the
beginning
he uh he's a Ministry official
which we we had said I had said that
maybe he's a Ministry official before
but now we got that confirmed so much to
talk about
so our uh our streams the Tuesday
streams start at 8 pm Eastern
8 P.M oh dude have we done this part
I remember this at all
oh wait and then the dragon comes out
right
I feel like there was a scene right
there with the dragon
dude the game really should tell you how
many
if you have any Shields left
we don't even know guys we could be
exploring this for no reason
oh my goodness I haven't even seen we
might have to take inspector's advice we
might have to just be stuck in the
herbology level as painful as it is oh
there's one right there let's go
it's at the top there you guys see it
and if I'm right I'm pretty sure so we
only have two levels left in the game
there's the final task and then one
called Voldemort
but I think to be able to face Voldemort
I think we're gonna have to do this
whole dog and pony show again I think we
have to find even more
even more Travis or Shields
before you can progress to the end
new theory for the day Fig's wife Miriam
was a goblin what
dude have we ever had any confirm has
there ever been any like Goblin wizard
relationship like that I don't think so
I still feel like goblins are too I mean
they're not human first of all
they are not human so they have
Tendencies aggressive tendencies that
can
you know make it difficult for them to
live and live harmoniously with humans
oh a phantom Wiki yeah yeah the fandom
the fanfic guaranteed absolutely you
know it's been done before
you know it's been done
it is Jared it's such a tedious way and
you gotta Wonder it's like did they have
these levels in place and then they ran
out of time like was it like you have to
have it out for the movie you don't have
time for anything else and so they just
had to start being like all right well
we got these levels we're just gonna
we're just gonna go back and hide these
things here or was it an actual choice
from the beginning I hope not all right
so we need three more herbology is by
far the most painful level in the game
however inspector says that is also the
home of some of the easiest
Shields to get in the game we've gotten
a few of them already
but
we just need three more to be able to
progress three more
[Music]
Draco good morning Draco how's it going
share and ever thought about doing a
video about the very first Hogwarts
Elite versus what we know now I
I've done that
I feel like I have that video somewhere
I definitely have videos where I I've
pulled up the old leak footage and talk
about it
but at this point I've made so many
Hogwarts like this videos I can't say
for sure
I can't say with 100 certainty if I did
or didn't
[Music]
oh we actually hadn't found that
collectible yet all right so the painful
part of the level happens once you go in
there
so let's just kind of I'm just gonna
walk through this
or wait no no no no no hold on hold on
go through the greenhouse and there will
be a location at least two Shields
all right so I remember last time
inspector we went through the gate here
do I need to go back like back back
track through the greenhouse
let's go ahead and open this up
enjoy some herbology right here we go
welcome to Greenhouse three second years
in this case we're fourth years
oh no
hold on this is the this is the bad room
I'm just gonna glance I'm just gonna
glance around I'm just running by you
guys don't hit me please oh you can't go
all the way around what that's painful
that is painful that I can't just run
all the way around
yeah I don't I don't think there's
anything I think we got everything out
of that room
backtrack okay gotcha
don't remember if there's any Shields
beyond the gate all right perfect
because
I mean the beginning of the level is bad
but
it's not quite as bad as some of these
other parts here
somebody was asking about Dobby earlier
yes so Dobby if you're talking about
Dobby for Hogwarts Legacy nah Dobby
Dobby would be much later
this game oh my goodness no they're so
they're just so quick they're so quick
with that strike
so Dobby came much later
[Music]
there we go nice
[Music]
the game takes place in the late 1800s
and it's also weird that the game
doesn't just automatically start you
mac and cheese how did I used to like
these video games
well the first three I'll say were good
they were good all right you know what
let's let's do it let's let's do our
[Music]
foreign
there we go
our ancient magic powers
it's gonna make us more powerful for
these guys oh dude dude maybe that's the
keys you see how quickly that took him
out
it was just two casts and he was down
[Music]
maybe that is the key
our ancient magic is actually useful
yeah I guess that's true like we don't
really know
how long how cells live do we
it's hard to believe he'd be older than
Dumbledore though
very hard to believe
all right you know what can I get that
pumpkin pasty from over here I don't
think we can
good morning Christy how's it going
welcome
I know right it's just like a totally
different vibe on these early streams
we're not used to this guys we we uh for
those of you who may be watching for the
first time we normally stream in the
evenings we do a Tuesday night live
stream
every Tuesday evening talking right now
talking all things Hogwarts Legacy but
once the game's out we'll uh we'll shift
into more just just gaming gaming news
and and Wizarding World too of course
[Music]
oh no there they are dude there they are
see it's like it doesn't even give me
time they get two hits in before he can
even stand up quite quite literally
before Harry gets to stand up
and there's no lock-on feature so I'm
trying to actually destroy that last
mosp right there but instead of
destroying him Harry just starts to
blast the
the next lily pad over here
date of birth Dobby is unknown
go go go
no no no no
I don't even remember which way I just
want to get off of this little like
Island that we're on right now
inspector's probably going to tell me
nope you went the wrong way
all right so we backtracked though we
have backtracked
oh I feel like there might be something
kind of over here to this bottom right
corner but also what is this here for
can we did I seriously just okay yep it
did
it's seriously just damaged me when I
did that
was gonna see if I can destroy anything
over here because why put this over here
right
no okay maybe we can destroy one of
these pots over here
but you gotta get out of the way
Hermione you God
[Music]
no okay
they can live to around 200 years old so
there you go
I mean if that's the case then yeah we
we might be able to meet
oh creature dude imagine
imagine
I saw your comment Sharon imagine if we
actually met like a young creature oh
that would be so insane
okay the good news is at least we found
a tiny bit of Health along the way
all right so we're backtracking we're
backtracking making our way through so
now we're what two to go two to go
this is why I needed you all here this
is why I needed you all here to help me
get through this
so we are making our way through Harry
Potter and the Goblet of Fire we have
played the first three games on the
channel they are here Live on YouTube
go back you can watch those let's plays
and now we are trying we are attempting
to make it through Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire which is one of the most
frustrating here
why here why not the beginning of the
level
two more keep believing I know him you
sore and then then we get the the bad
news of how many we have to get to
progress to the final level
I'm afraid to look
I'm very afraid to look at that one
just don't let these guys attack us
what we need what they should have done
like as a collectible
there should have been an unlock a cheat
code or whatever to get the invisibility
cloak
and once you have the cloak you could
just like go through nothing attacks you
see like that is terrible game design
when you can get hit twice before you
even get up
so it's like they punish you multiple
times
like there's nothing I can do to prevent
that second hit
he just appears out of nowhere first of
all
right so we're Max stamina build right
now guys Max stamina build
and we are just we're just sprinting
through here
now see this is what it works out well
if you can kind of get a little
separation from Ron and Hermione
and then they start actually doing the
they don't even have to destroy the
thing if they will just engage with it
you know
it keeps it off me for a bit
that one's just chilling over there he
doesn't seem to mind
right in the back side dude
oh he is he is like I think we're gonna
actually we have to confront him we
actually have to confront this one
no Harry
oh
see it's just painful there's no walk on
okay I think this is the last one I
think it's the last one for us to get
across
oh yeah there we go nice giant lily pad
Speed Run knowledge not happening
not happening
I'm just this is literally one of those
games it's like I I want to be able to
say yep I played it and I beat it and
that's it
that's all I care about I feel like we
already got whatever was over here
oh dude I see a mini Shield over there
all right I may be crazy for going for
this one
hold on let's see if that see if they'll
just go away
no that one's super close
this one's not I wouldn't even call this
game hard it's just
poorly designed in so many ways
not not quite broken
not broken
I knew it was gonna get hit right there
all right come on Hermione
like like just attack him
attack him
[Music]
okay then he just flies away I don't
understand it
[Music]
should have been my favorite I love the
chamber Secrets game
that one was my favorite one growing up
oh we gotta go all the way around oh
okay wait this one's actually kind of
weird right like how do we
okay launch that maybe and then can we
yeah and we could form the lily pad
but it's a short one
okay then maybe launch you
and then can I just walk over this there
we go okay not as bad as I was thinking
all right well that was worth it because
now we only need one more mini oh I do
this good time this might time perfectly
if we could find one more mini
right before we find the final big one
here
bait and run tactics yeah that's what we
need to do
bait our friends and then run
um but yeah so chamber Secrets I love
that one I really I've only played like
just a little bit of chamber on PC but
what little I played I I love that one
that one had the potential for me to
enjoy that even more
and then I did really like the Lego
games too some of you guys are talking
about the Lego games
I don't have I remember playing Five and
I remember it being like a solid game
that was when they actually really
started opening up the World opening up
Hogwarts
it was a little repetitive at times oh
no
I didn't even realize what I was walking
into here
all right so we're just on the lookout
for any easy
tri-wizard Shields that's what we're on
the lookout for
I never played the handheld ones Ryan
never played those
I did hear that some of them were pretty
good though
all right so I think this is where this
level originally originally this is
where you start
got the Lego games a few months ago
Ginny wow yeah so those if you're
starting with those then you're starting
with some of the better ones
they're they're fun they've got like the
open Hogwarts like you can explore
they're pretty basic you know they're
not incredibly difficult but just the
exploration and Lego games are always
good for the humor too they always have
some pretty humorous moments in them
foreign
Let's Open this gate
we gotta watch out for the little
spikes though
oh I've already been over here dude oh
but apparently not
apparently I did not find everything
that I needed
you know what why am I even bothering
why am I bothering with the health I
don't need it
the question is how in the world do we
get out here
can we like walk up this Vine right here
[Music]
because clearly there it has the places
where we can cast herbivicus
we know that spell now
all right this is one of those weird
camera tricks right
they do have the cauldron here too
[Music]
all right so maybe we have to like from
as Hermione just
blow up a Vine Maybe
blow up the wall yo there's inspector
we were getting there we were getting
there hold on wait did we just
gosh dude
oh my gosh
yeah backseat gaming guys for a game
like this Bring It On
Bring it on I told inspector that
some games newer games like Hogwarts
Legacy or when we play other games on
the channel I will very much be like no
backseat gaming guys I want to figure it
out this one bring on the back seating
Bring It On
all right we need one more one more to
be able to progress guys
and the good news is we also have nine
of the mini Shields right now so
regardless of which one we find next
mini Shield or the big one we are going
to be able to progress to the final task
finally
finally
all right so what do you think inspector
one more herbology round
or did I get the easy ones
Draco you never played a Lego game of
any kind oh man they're fun they're fun
like my sons they're really into the
Lego Marvel games we have a lot of fun
with those and then they my oldest son
got the platinum trophy and uh go to the
forest all right gotcha
[Music]
got the platinum trophy in Lego Jurassic
World
he had a lot of fun with that one
but yeah I need to at some point get the
trophies in the in the Lego games that'd
be fun
oh Lego Lord of the Rings I never played
those haven't played the Lego Star Wars
either twice I've heard good things
though yeah
all right we're gonna stick with stamina
for these situations when we need to
just Sprint through
grimly I've heard really good things
about Lego The Hobbit I read The Hobbit
to my oldest son probably about a year
or so ago
and we said we needed to uh we need to
play that game at some point
which I think it's on
I can't remember if it's on I need to
look and see if it's like digital on PS5
PS4 or if I have to play if I have to
get out my old PS3 to play it
in the force after you start go down
reach the crossroad with the wall and
then go up big cooldown can't backseat
oh if that's right we do have a
yeah we've got slow mode on here
I probably should have turned that off
for our gameplay streams whenever we do
our normal hangout streams the chat
flows very very quickly so we turn on
slow mode for that
but if your channel member you are not
subject to slow mode
all right so after you start go down
reach the crossroad with the wall and
then go up
all right I think this is the wall right
here
all right we're going up we're going up
and then
go up okay so we're in the right oh wait
what wait hold on maybe this is not the
wall maybe it's not the wall
Just Gonna Keep it oh there it is
there's one right there that's a mini
one but who cares
if there is another one that we can find
easier later wait wait why can we not oh
this is that weird one
that for whatever reason we can't cast
our spell on these guys not a crossroad
yet okay
let's see if we can figure this one out
without inspector
maybe it's just an accio
maybe it's just the wait what I thought
we were at nine
how are we just did eight mini Shields
what
I guess it's different for each level
inspector told us how that works last
time
and it was I thought I remembered how
but I guess I'm wrong
all right well we got eight on this
level too
we got eight here too
what is wrong Luna she wants out hold on
then she's gonna wind to come back in
ah you can only play Lego Lord of the
Rings on PS3 I thought so
I do still have my old PS3 I'd love to
play that with my son sometime
I need to pick that up
Luna's my uh my Westie my dog
okay so hold on let me see inspector not
a crossroad yet
all right maybe this ball
okay we got another cauldron up here
Lego Hobbit is on PS5 oh that's the one
I want to play with him for sure
because we we read that together
[Music]
all right so why are you lifting up the
rock Ron
what is what is this even over here
ah destroy mushrooms and go up
all right
hold on wait there's there's two
different mushrooms here probably these
mushrooms though I'm gonna guess these
mushrooms
[Music]
oh wait I thought we destroyed those
already I guess not
I guess no
[Music]
it's not launch
wow Ron way to get in the way right
there
oh yeah twice I thought I'd seen you
here before
most of the most of our regulars are are
familiar
are familiar with the Westy
maybe nope
dude they make you really you have to
get it just on there
ah golden retriever nice Sharon yeah if
you guys are in our uh Discord
exclamation point Discord in the chat if
not we have a section there where you
can uh
share your pets
probably my favorite section of the
whole Discord honestly
[Music]
everybody has such adorable pets
oh my goodness it's a scrute
foreign
can I just use like my nope
I was like can we just use accio on the
big one oh wait there's another mini one
though all right that's okay that's nine
all right we got a definite nine over
here
is the screw not even gonna attack me
okay you know what there might be an
even easier one
okay let's just fight him let's just
let's just get rid of him
foreign
there we go
there we go Harry
focus focus focus
Perfect cast
oh he just ran into the fire right there
he just ran right into the fire
all right for some reason Harry's trying
to put out the fire instead of casting
it on the Scrooge come on dude
hey thank you for the subscription there
welcome
yeah we're not we're not targeting him
correctly here
Jake what's up dude welcome there we go
all right he's taken out now
so let's just put out all the fires I
don't know that actually is gonna do
anything or give us anything
oh and now this one lowers nice okay so
we gotta remember though there was
another area up there where you could go
further
could be something else there but we
finally did it
we are ready to progress
ladies and gentlemen
I'm gonna do a little stretch here
Mr Jingles oh what a great name Go Ninja
what a great name and also uh kipo or
kaifo HD welcome thank you for
subscribing
all right we finally did it guys we're
ready to progress ready to move on
[Music]
and what I'm afraid of seeing is how
many it's gonna take to unlock the final
level
to actually be able to take on Voldemort
all right so try was your task three oh
and it just says locked it doesn't tell
us yet it will probably tell us after we
beat this level
all right so this should be the maze
and I don't remember this one at all
earlier this evening Professor Moody
placed a try wizard cup within the maze
only he knows where it resides
Professor Moody
hmm I'm all suspicious
don't know about you guys I'm I'm Tad
suspicious
Champions prepare yourselves you go
straight to Voldemort
yes yes
we might actually be able to beat the
game today guys
you might be able to meet the beat the
game
a book movie location everyone's excited
visits he can't wait to see the Great
Hall I mean yeah the Great Hall it's
hard to compete with that we do already
have a glimpse of the common rooms
um
let's see what else there's gonna be so
many there's gonna be so many good ones
wait we're timed why are we getting
timed here
all right I wonder if I'm supposed to go
oh dude so it's just like an actual mace
it's like
with the most bizarre camera angle
okay so can we actually progress here or
no
all right one two three now we take off
running
nice
quidditch pitch
yeah what if we can actually like fly
around the Quidditch pitch but you can
just you just can't play it
oh man
I mean that might that might be that
might be some people if you can just fly
around a little bit
I have no idea what I'm doing by the way
I'm just like
roaming mindlessly through this
yeah Jake
and hope you're enjoying your day off
that's why I'm streaming because we were
off work today as well
I mean I feel like I feel like we're
progressing
I feel like we're progressing so the cup
is at the center of the maze
but dude it is actually really
expansive like if you look out over
there
fly to the top of the castle
I mean it's just there's so many things
people are gonna the will want to do
a lot of people I think are gonna go
look straight ahead for Chamber of
Secrets
[Music]
first time watching you live hey thank
you for being here Rohan or Rohan
I'm doing well just hanging out playing
one of the worst Potter games but hey
hanging out with Chad here makes it all
worth it
don't remember the way through the maze
inspector says no
no oh dude that just closed oh that just
closed
I don't know if that's good or bad
crucio what the heck who's casting
crucio here
somebody in here Cassidy crucio
all right so maybe that's just kind of
like pointing us oh frames frames
and it looks like we don't have Ron and
Hermione with us in this one either I
guess that's the other Champions that
we're hearing there we go
yo Cedric thank you buddy
stand on top of the astronomy Tower and
look out over the scenery what is this
[Music]
it's like old school Crash Bandicoot or
something I'm gonna go left
don't know if that's the correct way no
the thorns
foreign this was a part in the movie Man
like the maze they just
I mean I get why they made some of the
decisions they did but just did not
match or come anywhere close to as cool
as it was in the book
[Music]
the other the first two tasks I'll give
them credit for that one you know Goblet
of Fire not everybody's favorite movie
there's a lot of issues with that one
but the first two tasks I feel like they
did a solid job of bringing those to
screen even if the first one they did
like you know with the dragon task
they added quite a bit of quite a bit of
theatrics to that understandable
but this one there's like so many more
cool things they could have done like
with the riddle and the Sphinx
the creatures that were in there and
they're just like nah let's just have
like
let's just save on our budget here of
our of um
graphics and everything we're gonna have
like these Vines and some sort of
mysterious smoke that chases Harry no
and in the game it looks like they've
taken the same approach
they have taken the same approach oh
goodness
back and forth back and forth back and
forth
boom there we go
[Music]
and if you're just tuning in guys so the
music here is not the music that you're
hearing is not from the game but it's uh
or copyright issues so we have to
have to mute that free Cedric what in
the world
boom nope didn't do anything all right I
was afraid of that
[Music]
oh no we got to get them to run into the
uh oh my goodness that did major damage
on me no no all right all right there we
go there you go okay he smacked the wall
this one's
[Music]
all right come on come on come on
is he doing anything to him
I don't think it did I I don't think it
did anything
it makes it very hard to see there's no
like Dodge button you can't roll
they give you these rocks here like
you're supposed to use them though
should I just smack you with the rock oh
man we're definitely going down in this
level we are definitely going down here
24 health
all right come on come on come on come
on come on finish that one off no Harry
oh oh dude
no way so the chocolate frogs here all
right good thing we hit the cut scene
so it looks like the chocolate frogs do
nothing you can't
can't respond with them only redeeming
point of this game might be they at
least made a few creatures in the Maze
yeah I see that now that we got to the
end
the screws
all right so you got I gotta get you to
charge me
okay charge nope nope nope nope nope all
right just get out of the way Harry get
out of the way
get out of the way
all right come on dude
foreign
charge at me there we go
all right nice nice nice come on get out
of this
get out of this Harry
why is nothing happening
Jinx their tails I thought you have to
do Aqua you recto on them
inspector
oh dude this is bad oh dude there
they're annihilating me
salty they didn't keep the whole
dragon that fights Harry is Norbert
thing
wait what
that wasn't a thing
are you saying you wish that would have
been a thing
[Music]
it's a it's a horn tail in the books too
[Music]
all right
no I can't get to the other guy when
he's doing this annoying spray
no The Mazes the maze is pretty
different it's still a maze but
they're like these riddles that Harry
has to solve throughout it's not as
I don't know it's not as like uh I mean
there are parts of it that are sort of
frantic but it's not as frantic as it is
in the movie
foreign
I'm just getting destroyed
come on charge at me there we go there
we go all right now okay
Jinx is not doing anything I think you
yeah I think you have to do aqua erupto
that's what we've been doing literally
this whole
what is why is it not oh wait wait wait
wait he kind of fell down where we
actually
foreign
I think that might be some head Cannon
for you
I think that might be some head Cannon
so Norbert was a Norwegian Ridgeback
and then the dragon that Harry fights in
the first task is a Hungarian horntail
in both the books and movies
just keep hitting the Tails till they
explode what
oh my goodness after they run into me
though right like
all right there you go
oh he didn't get dizzy because he didn't
hit the wall
yeah might as well might as well just
reset let's just reset
just reset
[Music]
I've heard Robin yeah I've heard that
the final two games are even worse
I now see those I had zero experience I
played this one as a kid but those I
have zero recollection of didn't play
them
I think it's so funny that they put
these rocks in here man
[Music]
come on run into each other run into
just run into it
laughing stock welcome how's it doing
Harry Potter is dead
yeah we're getting we're getting uh
no no no
no dude that did such insane damage are
you serious all right so I'm just gonna
hang out over here come on gas Jinx is
on You Look At Me
look at me there we go all right
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom we're
just we're just like spamming it here
we're spamming it we're spamming it oh
my gosh inspector inspector with the
clutch the clutch help again
all right let's get you to charge me
let's get you to charge come on come on
come on dude
oh he didn't hit the wall really
you didn't hit the wall
[Music]
Dylan oh hold on Dylan just posted like
a huge riddle or something
foreign
no now he's doing that the acid no I
cannot do this again you guys I do not
want to have to fight both of them again
I'm just gonna go way away from them
it's gonna go way away while spinning
attack
block the attack with the rocks are you
is that actually work
no way I knew there had to be a purpose
for the rocks
okay boom there we go all right all
right all right maybe we're finally
about to be done with this
uh Gryffindor Robin Gryffindor for me
I know boring right boring and
traditional but that's that's my house
gotta go with that first playthrough
go on take it no Cedric we must take it
together
bronze don't even care dude don't even
care if we got bronze on that
don't even care
[Music]
all right here we go
we we're at the end we're at the end
guys I think we can beat it right here I
think we can actually beat the game much
faster than I was expecting honestly I
was kind of worried to be totally honest
I was a bit worried that this was going
to take a while
to go and get all of those uh crests or
Shields clova thank you for subscribing
to the channel welcome
you only own book three on your reread
oh yeah yeah
it was uh it was definitely Hungarian
horntail in the books too
that would that would have been kind of
cool though if that's how it took place
all right yes no try wizard Shields
required guys we are ready for the final
battle
against Voldemort and we will be able to
officially say that we have beaten
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire
all right here we go we're diving in
final level
now see most if the game is actually fun
I'd be like oh let's go and find
Collectibles let's go let's go and uh
let's let's 100 this
Cedric get back to the cup now
I'm not leaving you kill the spare
no
um
we have to we have to do our own voice
acting guys Harry Potter
the boy who lived
I'm going to destroy you Harry
crucio oh but he wants to torture him
first oh dude look how big he is oh my
gosh
come on Harry let's see what school boy
spells you have up your sleeve
Schoolboy spells Voldemort you know what
you know what spells just like
absolutely dominate you man
where is it all right I got I I got a
feeling we're gonna have to okay wait
throw skeletons
wait wait wait hold on
okay
we have to throw them at him
how do we actually get them to do damage
to him though
oh my goodness
oh well done Harry
and you're tired of our duel
never
stop Harry your parents would be proud
yeah guys we we can't have the in-game
sound dude copyright but
we're making it work we're making it
work all right is this actually doing
anything to him I have no idea
I want you to look at me when I kill you
get real Angry on that one
okay wait
wait
wait
wait
launch it at him Harry come on
I have no idea if we're doing even doing
the right thing
just destroy skeletons okay so it's just
like a time thing I guess like you just
gotta destroy enough of them
not feeling this one
skip the song
launch you I actually don't even know
how we yeah launch you
I don't think this does anything to them
oh it does it actually does
you played this level so much
wait now can we actually attack him hold
on oh there we go
Expelliarmus yes
yes
hold on I don't even know what I'm doing
am I supposed to tap I'm just I'm
tapping a right now
whoa okay hold on it looks like we're it
looks like
it looks like we're actually working
together on this
I have no idea wait hold on okay we kind
of all right all right hold on wait I'm
seeing what's happening here I can use
this this Center beam of the spell
to destroy these skeletons here
I can control this
there we go
what do you think about that Voldemort
oh my goodness
bow to death Harry
oh dude he's having to resort to
he's like I can't just AK this kid so
you know what we're gonna cause a giant
statue
we're gonna use the statue to smash him
right you know what I've been kind of
saving this cauldron cake over here
there we go there we go
oh there's another one over here on the
left
destroying Voldemort's crayons
I'm gonna can I not force it right on
him nah not yet it's like a timed thing
probably
you don't want me to do that again oh
dude I wish I could hear this
I wish we could have this on right now
your mother can't help you now oh just
just you wait bro just you wait
your ignorance of the ancient Magic
something you should have foreseen
Voldemort
oh oh no oh no he's actually doing some
damage to me now no 27. all right I
can't figure out what we're supposed to
be doing at this point
attack the statue when it lands wait
wait come on
come on
there we go a little bit maybe maybe
if it looks like I'm just all over the
place with this thing it's because of it
I totally am
the the controls on this are like the
wonkiest
there's like there's no Precision to it
at all no we're at Seven health Harry
what are you doing
no I see where you are no no no we gotta
get this we gotta get this pump capacity
yes gave us 10 Health though that's not
enough no
we're not playing hide and seek I I
question what we're playing Tom
I I legit question what we're playing
right now
no did I lose what
what
no all you have to do the whole thing
again
oh jeez Voldemort oh
GG right
all right okay Jinx skeletons and then
we could throw skeletons with B
I'm just gonna jinx them from now on
that's it Harry cast your school boy
spells
to be honest Tom don't even know what
I'm casting here this whole game we just
there's been like two buttons for spells
I can't set any of them
I tell you dude the education they've
got at Hogwarts these days yeah
this level is annoying whatever whatever
their education system was
for Goblet of Fire
it's weak man it's very very weak
goodness all right there we go skeleton
down
and we went into that pretty much full
health
all right what's your what's your
guidance inspector I know you got to
wait a bit for super for the uh for the
chat
to reset for you but um
I mean I feel like the first part of the
fight's pretty easy it's when you get to
the part with the Statue I have no idea
what I'm supposed to be doing I saw the
one comment saying that
you can like
uh
do something like cast spells on the
Statue when it's
oh wait I think we can run up to him now
wait what did we just glitch something
is it glitched is it glitched
what is happening
why no game audio I know help I know
it's uh
copyright unfortunately
copyrighted music
on our last
on our last
um let's play so we have let's play up
on the channel or part two
there is a section where
it got flagged for copyright
pretty unfortunate so we're just we're
just playing with some background music
and I've just got it the sound muted
but I agree yeah I wish we could hear
game audio right now
come on there we go all right so yeah
move energy spell to smash skeletons
that makes sense
so you do have some control over this
energy spell but man I tell you guys it
is so
just it's like all over the place like
it's just flying
it is not Precision control at all
okay so yeah you do have to you have to
exactly what the other comment said
Thank You inspector yeah yeah that's
that's what I was thinking I was hoping
I was missing something
it's just the controls dude they're so
ridiculously bad
all right get over here Harry because
like not only is it controlling this
spell the left stick it's also
controlling
it's also controlling Harry
it's also controlling Harry it's so
annoying
I checked for that Dan I don't think it
has any yeah see they don't have any
it's an old school game they don't have
that option unless you have to go to
like main menu or something
foreign
but I I checked and couldn't find it
dude I can't move
all right we gotta get these we gotta
get these skeletons out of the way
and then we'll try to go for the oh
there it is it did freeze like I can't
even this energy ball guys I can't even
direct it properly
this is like gotta be some of the worst
design oh my gosh I need to get over
here to get this cauldron
all right no down to 32.
I can't move like I can't move please
just aim it Harry right there aim it aim
it aim it
come on bow to death Harry I can feel
death coming
I feel it approaching
okay see a couple times it like lands
and then he very quickly gets back up
with it all right I'm just gonna try to
stay back here where we can move back
and forth
oh my gosh dude
maybe we need a music change hold on
here's what we're gonna do
we can't go with the in-game music but
maybe we can at least go I mean I think
it's so chill for what we're seeing
right
right I'm pretty sure you're right
though
um Dan on the other games like once we
get there I know for sure that the Lego
games have that option all right
hold on hold on
foreign
we got to get something to like pump us
up a little bit here let's see
maybe maybe
[Music]
all has to be copyright free guys since
we're on YouTube
okay yeah here we go here we go
all right
[Music]
all right Voldemort that's it we've had
enough of your games
you've had enough of your skeletons
must be one thing if they gave you a way
to to dodge
but no there's no Dodge
like I can't even roll out of the way
spam endlessly with this music it's
cracking me up
hold on let's see if I can cast the
spells in time with the music
[Music]
here we go ready ready
oh
hold on hold on we gotta wait for it to
drop again
but we're not gonna We're not gonna wait
for the skeletons we have to fight them
I know right it does look like he's
dancing
somebody's gonna find this let's play
years from now
gonna be like what is happening
or if they just skip around and they
miss the part when I'm explaining why
the music is the way it is
all right I actually feel like when
guardian might be a little bit faster on
these guys if you
nope I just gently laid him down
sometimes you can like crash them into
each other
like Harry why do you attack that one
when this one's right in front of your
face
okay there we go see that one I threw
him right into the other one
[Music]
oh there we go just gotta lift him up
really high drop him
[Music]
what do you got now Voldemort what do
you got anymore
[Music]
yes now we got the disco ball chat
We Got the Disco all going now
it's perfect
Rave in the grave I should that's what I
should title this video
oh no oh no oh no no no
all right I'm not gonna I think the
little cauldron cakes and I'll give you
like 10 Health
so I'm at 92 we're still fine
and we have one over here on the right
that we can
the problem is we just can't get to it
quickly because the controls are so
imprecise at this section right now
oh no we lost our disco music maybe the
next one will be equally as
maybe the next one will be
equally
about death Harry
[Music]
oh no no no no no no no no no
oh no I don't know what this one is dude
I don't know
oh no hold on
no we we gotta no
we gotta have something better than that
oh no it's frozen it's Frozen can we hit
it okay I think it actually collided
with it right there maybe
Maybe
[Music]
Jared laughing so hard hey glad I could
make your morning or afternoon evening
whatever it may be
all right we're about to beat this guy
man oh yes yeah we definitely hit him I
saw it slightly change
[Music]
it's Voldemort come on as you go out
I can't see him my Lord
all right now in what is a very
emotional moment
I mean hold on are we are we are we
about to leave or is there more to the
level okay we're about to leave all
right so now now now we gotta change
dude
[Music]
he's back
Voldemort spot
oh yeah this is a very somber one very
somber here
[Music]
yeah here we go
with dark and difficult times comes a
choice between what is right and what is
easy
should you have a waiver remember Cedric
Diggory a boy who was kind and brave and
true
[Music]
dang dude
Oh I thought they were in the prefix
bath
second
no matter how convincingly you tell the
story of what happened tonight few will
believe that Voldemort has returned
tell the story
you must